[Music]
one hundred years ago this week a double
murder an hour outside new york city
became a front page sensation launching
the popularity of a new type of
newspaper called a tabloid
filled with intrigue lies and an illicit
affair the fascinating story is detailed
in a new book called blood and ink by
vanity fair writer joe pompeo
we sat down with pompeo in new brunswick
new jersey at the church where the
victims a reverend and a singer in his
choir
met for the first time
a century ago america was emerging from
years of war and pandemic
ready to roar into the 20s
in the 1920s i think people were looking
for things to
obsess over you know that were
you know didn't have to do with the war
they just come out of this pandemic that
had you know the period of the country i
mean it was coming back to life after
this really dark time and i think the
hall mills
story as well as other sensations of the
roaring 20s and the jazz age people just
loved following these things
this is the morning of september 16th
1922.
in a field near new brunswick new jersey
two locals discovered two bodies
a man and a woman
both had been shot
left down a secluded road
in a very specific way the bodies were
positioned next to one another in a pose
that clearly suggested some sort of
intimacy uh you know her his arm was
outstretched and her head rested on his
arm
her hand had been placed on his thigh
you know most telling of all there was a
stack of papers between them these were
love letters
love letters documenting the
relationship between the victims
both married but not to each other
one a prominent church leader the
reverend edward hall
the other a choir singer named eleanor
mills
we're sitting in the place where edward
and eleanor may have met
for the first time you know this is this
is certainly kind of the you know ground
zero of their love affair you know and
they would after choir practice they
would sometimes disappear to his his
study which is still you know there's a
room over there which is his study and
they would leave
their love notes in different in hymnals
or there was a book on his bookshelf i
mean all of a lot of the intrigue
happened in this very literally in the
very place where we're sitting right now
the case was full of sex scandal
and speculation
was the reverend's older wife and
heiress worth millions the one
responsible
was it her oddball brothers
was it eleanor mills husband who
certainly had his own motive
or someone else
the story was tailor-made for a whole
new brand of journalism
you know newspapers they've been
obsessed with crime and murder going
back to you know the penny press of the
victorian era and certainly the hearst
and the pulitzer papers and the yellow
press the turn of the century you know
people followed this stuff but this was
the first time there was a new
medium which is you know the tabloid
press covering things like this you know
with photographs one tabloid the
up-and-coming new york daily news went
so far as to try to elicit a confession
from eleanor mills husband
by staging a seance
as joe pompeo writes in his new book
blood and ink the scandalous jazz age
double murder that hooked america on
true crime this was the o.j simpson case
of its day you had about 300 reporters
from all over the country that were you
know trekking around you know all the
hotels are booked up they're renting out
houses
[Music]
despite unprecedented attention the case
lingered for years
until it was revived by another tabloid
police used the media attention
along with the accounts of a mysterious
local farmer known as the pig woman to
bring the case to trial
charging the wife of the reverend and
her brothers
in perhaps the most dramatic testimony
the country had ever seen
the pig woman deathly ill by then
was wheeled into a courtroom
on her hospital bed but at the very end
you know she's being wheeled back out
and she raises her voice and she looks
at francis hall in points and she says
i've told the truth and you know i've
told the truth so help me god it's like
if this was a movie
you couldn't make that line up
[Music]
when the trial was over frances hall and
her brothers were acquitted
and successfully sued the tabloid
but the story didn't end there
and in fact
never has
100 years later
will this crime ever be solved
i don't know what testing you could do
at this point to to determine anything
um there's a there's people who who very
much want to solve this crime these sort
of amateur detectives and historians
there's there's a facebook group where
you know this community of people who
are obsessed with this crime but i think
also with stories like this i think what
makes them so powerful is that we don't
know and i think that's you know to me
um i think that's what gives a story a
lot of it's of its power and mystique
and we want you to solve the case
jeffrey
i was trying to solve the case as i'm
reading the book and as i'm walking
around new brunswick right here um and
everybody does who approaches this story
because it does remain and it's hard to
imagine it ever being solved but now we
could
feel free to investigate it this was a
media circus it really was before media
circus yeah yeah one of the original
yeah um and um and the book is a
fascinating trip through through history
yes but it was on my yeah sounds like a
good one thanks jeff